as the horror movie Experts of the
franchise can you kind of tease Mindy's
interactions with Kirby and what it was
like finding the right tone for those
conversations well I will reference the
Twitter threads that happened after it
was announced that Hayden would join us
this film no one will be disappointed
The Mindy Kirby interactions will make
you very happy
um and maybe you'll have to pick a side
it's true the banter's response spot on
can confirm some of that but I refuse to
pick a side I will be on both sides
forever and ever all right Mason my
non-spoiler question for you now so Chad
gets credit with dubbing the group The
Core four what do you think it is about
him that kind of makes him you know the
glue that binds and did you ever realize
he had that quality in him in Scream
five I think it's why he enjoys a sport
like football I think he's just a team
player
um I think something memorable about
Chad is how willing to cooperate and
listen to the women in his life and sort
of allow that to guide him in his uh I
guess in this case navigating
um a murderer but uh for Chad
specifically I think he enjoys being a
part of a family in something greater
that's why he you know uh loves his
sister so much but it's also why he
tries to like bring in and be there for
the people he cares about whether petar
or Tara or Sam I know I do that all the
time you're not the first person I've
heard say that though oh yeah I'm bad he
did it a lot on set which contextually
it's quite funny but um yeah